today oh shoot oh no I pressed the alarm
wait why is the elevator making that
noise just give me an intense video I've
been seeing all these 24-hour challenges
on YouTube and I thought I might give a
shot so today I'm gonna be spending 24
hours in an elevator
[Music]
the moment I step over
let me grab some water I guess the
moment I step in the elevator I'm not
going to be able to get out so it's just
gonna start um just gonna start right
now
I'm inside Oh Mike I feel like I should
have gotten stuff and like prepared it's
empty it's got like a good amount of
room I really don't like when elevators
move I always feel like they're gonna
fall feels like there's a lot of air in
here and maybe the only thing that's
gonna bother me is the light it's like
very bright fluorescent light and it's
obviously not gonna turn off at night
[Music]
where are we going now why does it keep
going up and down I'm gonna get nauseous
wait what the hell there's nothing it's
just what it's just blinking X why am I
freaking out I'm not gonna it's just an
elevator where is it going though I
don't like that I don't have control
over where they all go about stopping
very clear before I'm spending 24 hours
in the elevator what do you think
I'm spending 24 hours in the elevator
are you really yeah this seems like a
really bad idea yeah
[Music]
my head's starting to hurt because we're
going up and down so much like yours
keep popping just it needs a break can
this elevator go on break for a little
bit man I could just step out right here
and I'll be freed so awkward not leaving
the elevator when everybody else leaves
I think I have a break
yes it's not moving I'm really getting
dizzy I'm gonna sit down have some water
real quick it's the longest break I've
gone so far going up no okay we got
another break lobby big no-no seven
floor 15 I'm getting so nauseous should
I pull for the emergency stop why did it
stop on the 13th floor now the elevators
just stopped on random floors whenever
they're not in using intake braze it
smells weird like if someone brings food
in someone just came in with yogurt and
left and now it smells like yogurt it
like traps the smells or whatever
someone brought farts I'm gonna kill
them oh my god please no more people it
hasn't stopped it hasn't stopped okay
it's so hot he's like oh I knew this
time would come but like I really gotta
take a piss
I got a little break
no it's started moving and I laid down
for one second I feel like I'm gonna go
crazy in this little white room this I
tried to do some yoga and workout just
to like have some sort of activity to do
but it's really scary is that you can
feel the elevator like bounce and stuff
and I just feel like it's gonna fall so
ah can't do it anymore okay no I can't I
can't board so I'm gonna call my mom hey
how are you
I'm living in an elevator for 24 hours
[Music]
all right I love you I think I'm gonna
call a friend and ask them to like bring
me something hey it's Eric calling if
you listen to this voicemail hey this is
Eric de baak please bring me stuff to
the elevator it's Eric tomorrow I have
called every single person on the video
team and nobody's picked up on me
I can't leave and I didn't bring it up
inside so I need you to bring some stuff
well I'll I'll shout out your Instagram
in the video right now all right
[Music]
all right so I'm outside the elevators a
BuzzFeed there's four options I think
Ericsson number five he said so I just
got to hit this button and hopefully he
comes down or keep hitting him until he
comes down so each five okay here we go
no what is happy what if it starts going
like 1920 the top of the Charlie the
Chocolate Factory
well here we go how are you feeling Kyle
yeah I mean I definitely 13th floor
right go grab chair little desk my
computer and you just take this alright
I got you the pillow and don't be mad at
did give you something and just a cup of
starbursts I'm gonna die I'm not I'm
gonna like literally die can I is this
can I survive off this sugar oh oh sorry
who's joining hey come in oh my god can
I have those groceries I'm staying in
this elevator for 24 hours any period
and he brought me starbursts goodnight
thank you enjoy your regular bedroom
yeah I've never seen I've never seen any
of these faces and awkward and quiet and
not this elevator I'm lighting you
though yeah it's full of fun and
conversation starters yeah it's really
not that much smaller than our room our
room is literally this is what a New
York City apartment slightly updated you
out do be bop bop baby's arrived do bop
bop David around
okay so Kyle left because he got bored
and nauseous yeah you really really get
nauseous in here like you know people
like standing that elevator and press
the button they go up and down with you
I don't know how they use all day
because I literally I can't even stand
I'm I feel really really dizzy dip the
chair you just left me a pillow so I'm
just probably gonna go like to sleep
sometime soon the security guard didn't
want to be on camera but they ordered
too much neat set so he gave me a whole
pizza pie so I'm gonna eat a little bit
even though I'm like feeling dizzy and
weird one latigo out of the you know
disease though I - I'll keep cozy broom
I can't eat anymore
try literally only I had one slice and I
feel sick I'm gonna sleep
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what
that was so creepy pushing finding their
security cameras I got to just go back
to bed
all right so it's it's not him people
should be getting here somewhere around
now I slept pretty fine like I it took
me a little while to get comfortable and
fall asleep at some point I just fell
asleep and kind of slept through it but
yeah as soon as my friends get here like
co-workers someone asks him to bring me
some food and my stuff so I can work and
just like get rid of the pizza I just
have to pull it off till 4:00 I think
I'm gonna be buried before going up good
morning
the elevator and all night I totally
forgot how annoying is for the other
moment all right so my friends bought me
some breakfast like tea and granola bar
and they got me my backpack
[Music]
the up-and-down of the elevator is made
me really really sick so I'm dying just
have a couple hours left I'm not gonna
quit now so I'm just gonna try and sleep
again I honestly don't care
[Music]
four minutes left I feel so sick I can't
even see what I'm filming my eyes like
in Calvary but I did you can't happen
[Music]
I made it out oh my god I smell fresh
air ah the ground is definitely still
moving and I feel like unstable but oh
my god I'm gonna go get like food and
water
i frickin did it I've accomplished
nothing
why am I even excited I've literally
wasted 24 hours to be logical
[Music]
it's eerie puzzle soprano Fiore
[Music]